hello everyone and welcome back to the
semi-finals of the uh Fisher random
world championship this is game four
from the matiani bomji versus Magnus
Carlsen and even though the match
started by Magnus winning the first game
uh Nepal retaliated by winning the
second one Magnus made a terrible
blunder and then in the third game uh
nepo just crushed Magnus in a miniature
uh again after Magnus severely
blundering uh and now this is a game
four this is the final chance for Magnus
to save the match and get back into the
game or Nepal will proceed to face uh
whoever won between uh Hikaru nakura and
another of uh in in the other semi-final
match which we are also going to discuss
uh now let's check out the game uh Ken
Magnus bounce back with the black pieces
it's nipple with white and he opens with
Knight to G3 and the Magnus uh plays
Pawn to F6 it's a weird move yes but um
it's it's a much needed one if you uh
this is one of the rare Fisher random
positions where you can immediately
blunder the game on on move one to give
you an example if you try to mirror
white you play Knight to G6 already
Knight F5 and you're pretty much lost
against a strong player how do you stop
Knight captures on G7 Checkmate uh it's
a really weird position you have to play
something like F6 and then give up a
pawn and then play King F7 then the
Knight goes out and okay you can
continue the game but you've blundered
the pawn and uh well that's no way to
play against anyone so after Knight the
G3 F6 uh no point in blundering right
away we have C4 and now Pawn to C5 and
now Knight to B3 or you could go B4
right away but okay Knight's the B3 we
have B5 by Magnus and now C captures on
B5 Pawn to C4
uh challenging the light here at night
the uh to D4 and now Pawn to E5 we have
Knight to F3 and now Pawn to G6 Magnus
creating a very very strong setup here
E5 uh D5 is coming uh and he wants to
push uh push those pawns uh so never
will have to be very careful where he
goes with the King we have Pawn to H3
and the D5 by Magnus and now comes the
bishop to H2 you could play A4 if you
want to be greedy but nepo is leading
the match you only need the draw in this
game to win he does not want to be
greedy he doesn't care about the B5 Pawn
he plays Bishop H2 aligns the bishop
nicely with the queen and now Magnus
just captures on B5 we have castles now
uh and Knight to B6 Magnus brings the
Knight into the game Pawn to E3 and now
Bishop to E6 with Pawn to B3 uh
preparing to open up the C file and now
uh Magnus also castles King side with B
captures and C4 Queen capture Sun B1
Rook captures and the D captures and C 4
and now Knights the E4 by nipple we have
H5 by Magnus and this is uh this is a
move where uh well Magnus Magnus is
doing quite well here but after H5 he
weakens his position uh maybe
unnecessarily he he he doesn't want to
see G for G5 on the board and that's why
he stops at Pawn to H5 but now nipple
has this beautiful Rook to B5 which he
spots and the The Rook here is just
incredibly strong as you'll see in lines
that follow uh Bishop to E7 with Bishop
to C2 now putting pressure on that G7
pawn and now just Knight to F7 so it's a
question can you move the Knight and
allow this x-raying of the of the Pawn
on G6 Well turns out you can we have
Knights the F7 and now just Rook after
B1 interestingly here a nipple went to
the bathroom when it was magnus's move
when Magnus was deciding a knight to F7
and then when he got back to the to the
table he sat down and then he
immediately played Rook F1 B1 he sort of
uh predicted Knight to F7 while being in
the bathroom but Knights the H4 was uh
uh you know worth considering yeah
because you are attacking the pawn here
and uh even though it seems like you
could maybe play something like F5
attack the Knight attacked the pawn here
there's this very nice Knight captures
on G6 and the bishop on E7 is hanging
with check uh so you don't have to worry
about anything but okay night stay
traded then again again defends the pawn
but maybe not Knight back to C3 and it's
a it's a very nice position just uh
maybe an idea now now the G6 Pawn is
attacked twice uh the Knight is nicely
placed on C3 and you have to figure out
how to play this because it it it's
definitely not easy probably going after
the D2 Pawn ignoring the G6 Pawn
altogether it would be a very
interesting game but uh Nepal decided
that okay not gonna do anything crazy
Rook after B1 just double up nicely on
the B file Rook F to d8 Magnus goes
after the D2 Pawn not right away the
knights are defending it but puts
pressure on the D file and now Rook to
A5 putting pressure on the A7 Pawn so
Magnus defends it and now Knight the C3
putting pressure on the G6 Pawn so
Magnus defends it King to G7 and now
Knight to B5 here again Knight stage
four is always very tricky but nepo goes
Knight to B5 he just puts more pressure
on the A7 pawn and now again Magnus
misses a chance to play this uh very
very annoying Rook to C5
uh it's just annoying because you
defended the A7 Pawn with a tactic and
it's a uh well and now the rookan A5
doesn't really look all that impressive
and you you can't capture if you capture
with the Knight of horse The Rook hangs
if you capture with the Rook then you
just play Rook captures on B5 and even
if Rook captures on D7 There's real
characters on B1 check and if captures
the Knight captures on D7 and if you
count the pieces uh black is up a full
night so okay after Knight B5 uh we have
Knights the D5 instead by Magnus and now
we have Pawn to A3 uh interestingly here
nepo again has the incredible Knight
beta D4 it's just a well just a stupid
move where you are asking black what
what's up with that Bishop on E6 that
has uh pretty much nowhere to go and if
you play e captures on D4 just Knight
captures you capture with the other
Knight and now uh too much stuff is
hanging for example you play something
like Knights the d8 you want to defend
the bishop there's Bishop to A4 and look
at this The Rook is hanging uh the the
bishop slices all the way uh here The
Rook controls B8 uh if you move the
bishop uh if you move the Rook then we
can just capture the bishop here and
then capture the Knight on D5 I mean
it's a disgusting position where white
is just completely winning uh but I mean
who who sees stuff like that but I mean
look at this bishop what what is that
Bishop doing but okay A3 by nipple
gaining control over the B4 square and
now Bishop to C5 we have rooked A6 now
putting pressure on the bishop and the
bishop to B6 locking out that Rook here
uh from attacking the bishop we have
Pawn to E4 chases the Knight away Knight
to C7 and now as the A7 Pawn is finally
up for grabs and apple goes for it
Knight captures on A7 also attacks The
Rook Here and Now Magnus uh has to
decide how to capture he decides the
trade Rooks Knight captures an A6 we
have Knight captures on C8 and the now
Bishop to C5 getting the bishop out of
Harm's Way Knight back to BC attacking
the other rook and now Rook the d8 by
Magnus you could also go Rook to D6 but
Rook to d8 is fine uh Knight's the D5
and now Knights to D6 and here the
situation on the clock is some nine
minutes for nepo in five minutes for
Magnus uh we have Pawn to D3 yeah
finally getting getting rid of that C4
Pawn uh C counters on D3 Bishop captures
opens up the light Square Bishop as well
and not Knights the B8 and uh now nepo
starts pushing his pass Pawn he is up a
pawn and if Magnus doesn't do something
magical with his Bishop's pair that pawn
is definitely going to be worth
something Sonic the D7 we have Knights
the D2 now the Knight can come to C4 at
some point with Bishop to A7 and now
Knight the B3 instead we have Pawn to G5
uh pump on to F5 also worth considering
Magnus starts pushing with the G Pawn uh
and now King to F1 nepo starts
activating the king Bishop captures on
D1 e captures and now Knights the B6 uh
sort of uh trying to trying to maybe get
nipple to go for 19 the C5 and while it
is a fine moved sort of threatening
Knight the E6 check with this Fork
there's Rook C8 and now it's very
unclear what is happening if you ever go
for this Fork just King F7 the Knight
isn't although on a fine Square isn't
doing all that much and now Magnus gains
control over the C file so instead he
goes for Knight the A5 and it's good
that he did because this move completely
confused Magnus uh here in this position
Magnus has to be very careful and he
should play something like Rook to D7
but he actually grabs the pawn on A4 and
well the nipple blunder upon or did the
Magnus just blunder by grabbing that
pawn you guys decided that feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
Nepal while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on kicking Magnus
out of the uh Fisher random World
Championship semi-finals and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course a knight to B7 this is
what Nepal played and he was in this
position on move 36 uh that Magnus
Carlsen resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here it's a
funny move to miss uh but what are you
gonna do uh the point is that the Rook
is hanging and also the Knight is
hanging and there's no way to deal with
this if you capture ninja through
captors and B7 with check also picks up
the bishop on A7 whenever you play
doesn't really matter King if it real
captures now you're just up a full piece
and also if you don't capture the B7
Knight what do you do you have to save
the rook and you can't move the Rook
just anywhere because the Knight hangs
you have to play something like Rook to
D7 and then of course you just capture
the Knight again and there's nothing for
black to do if you capture now then
again Rook the B7 track picks up the
bishop so Magnus blunders a piece uh in
a the championship semi-finals how is
this possible well it's hard to say but
uh it goes to show how how terribly
complicated official random is and how a
player like nippo who who even in
classical chess really plays just like
it's official random uh sort of thrives
in these uh crazy positions where Magnus
who who would prefer maybe a nice end
game uh didn't do all that great against
Nepal here even though yeah he crushed
him in the first game and he uh but the
second game the third game Magnus just
blundered terribly and then here also in
the final game he he blunders the Knight
a piece and uh okay uh even if you don't
play this it's still a better position
for nepo uh probably why he was so maybe
tense and why he was trying so hard to
create something because if it's a draw
the nipple wins uh but yeah this just
wanders a piece I mean it happens to
everyone it just doesn't happen to
Magnus that often usually he just puts
up a really stubborn defense for like
100 moves but here it would seem that he
was already out of energy or maybe some
other things are occupying his mind it's
it's hard to say but yeah other than
that a spectacular chest by Nepal uh
really nicely done and not only that
coming back from uh from A 1-0 Loss
against Magnus definitely not a pleasant
place to be yeah big congratulations to
nepo on the winning the semi-final match
against Magnus Carlsen he will now be
facing I will now disclose it he will be
facing Hikaru Nakamura in the finals as
Nakamura has defeated abdusattro and not
just defeated him he crushed him three
to zero so they didn't even need uh for
the game as Abu satro was unable to even
claim a draw against the mighty Hikaru
so yeah Hikaru nepo in the finals we'll
see what happens uh should be should be
a nice one uh that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Nathan Helsey Jacoby the more chess 960
morovo and Martingale paparik for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
finals of this fine event until it
finishes thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day